you want to try a virgin piña colada
from Puerto Rico yeah a virgin one yeah
oh you know what that means yeah Oh it's
sprinkling so I just finished having
breakfast but we decided to come outside
really quick check out the beach so we
are about to go petal 48
really not really so you kind of it good
though I've only been paddleboarding
once and that was a long time ago so I'm
really excited to check that out but
today's our one and only full day
recorder eco tomorrow morning we leave
so it's kind of said it's a really
really quick trip minute awesome so far
huh yeah like the horseback riding and
the frame for it
and today we're gonna go see old Sun
Quan rule
oh yeah we're still pretty tired luckily
though we had pretty nice sleep a night
we slept in pretty nice oh yeah yeah it
was really nice he was not up and in for
breakfast you were sleeping - sleeping
on my lap oh poor baby is so tired
[Music]
ramie but it's okay we're still down
we're gonna do this you ready it's a
pedal board in the rain yeah and it look
good yeah you got it
[Music]
so Isaac spell kick dude soaked just try
to figure out how to stand up okay see
already stood up have fun okay yeah he's
focusing on Isaac boom oh my words gonna
collide at the Isaac struggling a little
bit I'm saying on my knees right now
because I have more stability this way
especially since I'm trying to film this
but this is a cool experience in the
lagoon in Puerto Rico in the rain
hey baby you regret putting it on okay
we can dry it what do you think so far
paddleboarding is a little tricky huh
yeah it's awesome
[Music]
both of the kids have fallen in the
water splashing the water on my I am
loving the rain right the rain made it
extra cool yeah I decided to wear my
clothes I'm like yeah we'll be fine I am
I bathing suit under though I'm so glad
that the Sun isn't out honestly because
then we it'd be really really hot and we
probably get sunburned so this is
perfect like I couldn't have asked for a
better experience
this is amazing alright so we just
finished paddleboarding that was so fun
yeah you know with um you got six bring
in some things daddy and I didn't you
can you remember what it was that you
did that we didn't participate failure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah usually get up at that point yeah
you just make another say failure is not
a what
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah your failure actually turned out to
be a good thing it was like a positive
experience right yes something you would
failure by Isaac that's the call right
something you quote how do you
experience a bit yes
oh yeah you're both my babies and like
sometimes we're at home and I'll call
him Vivek but then he answers or
vice-versa
anyway don't worry before walking tour
old son
[Music]
what are you guys doing I'm punishing
him for we'll head for play boxing and
he's placed her loss
why do you have to be so vengeful you
know we haven't done in a long time
Isaac we haven't had a tickle fight in
forever
how about a pillow fight ha ha whoa your
butt's all wet no this is the side of
the bed I sleep on you cover you're
ready to go swim in the beach we have
some time yeah and then we're gonna go
have lunch already
yeah Isaac are you sure you still wanna
go swim at the beach look at this it's
pouring I don't think a single person
diving in the water
do you think you still want to try or
name cuz we're gonna be swimming in the
beach later on tonight because it's
Liana son Kwan so it's pretty awesome at
our trip just so happens to coincide
during the same time as at the end of
month one which is State John Baptist so
he was famous because in fact
there's something like that I'm really
bad handling I grew up Catholic but I
was a bad Catholic but anyway um so
today is a day that they celebrate him
and the way that they celebrate is that
every beach in Puerto Rico at midnight
because tomorrow is his birthday so
tonight midnight everyone's going to be
jumping in backwards into the ocean and
it's like kind of cleansing away bad
luck or just cleansing away for you know
the rest of the year until next year the
point is that it's a really cool
tradition and it just so happens to be
tonight at midnight and so we're
definitely gonna be doing that even
though our flight leaves really early in
the morning
we have to experience it I mean when it
when else are we going to be importer
Rico during this this very special
occasion
I am by the way we're right next to the
airport I don't know we pointed that out
but the airport is right there so all
last night we kept hearing the planes
come in but it was fine it wasn't it
wasn't too loud did the planes wake you
up baby oh no right it's pretty cool you
can hear them roaring in and land
right next to pretty awesome plan an
update on our luggage we got our luggage
so we that's how we're we want to change
we have new clothes by the way cute and
enjoying the day and rainy worried
though but it's still beautiful even
though the three meetings like I'm
having a blast
[Music]
hi I was having a great time I'm a
little chilly I have my legs in the
water though the waters really warm I
just didn't feel like getting completely
wet from the ocean but I am getting wet
in the rain so might as well right just
you could see Isaac and Casey swimming
away
[Music]
so tiny it looks look cute is bobbing
high wishes camera gizumon better we
didn't bring you the dad cam what are
you eating that is awesome
rice and beans baked with cheese it's
[Music]
like a rice stew don't most I'm like it
looks like Dumbo it's like a Puerto
Rican gumbo so good strong and clean
seafood flavor now what are you eating
right now Susan huh baba sandwich or
other political it of the valve sandwich
so it's a pulled pork avocado but I
actually need a lot of
so now I'm liking it I think
[Music]
camera work I don't know if you noticed
but in this vlog it's a little different
we decided to have two separate cameras
where I talk to you guys and then he's
in charge of all the pretty mural shots
this city is building
I mean we're probably gonna see more cuz
we're actually going on a three-hour
walking tour I see I really get hurt I
know that's why I told you to put shoes
we're wearing our shoes sandals listen
what does that mean did you translate
[Applause]
the paging whispers did you talking like
this and he's talking about the pages
[Music]
I cannot get over how gorgeous these
streets are they're just so beautiful I
asked our guiding he says that most of
the architecture around here is from
1516 century which is so pretty I love
it and love it it's so gorgeous
hey baby what do you think of the
building it's really uh he its
historical yep yeah
historical like there's a lot of history
yeah what do you think of the building
you like it pretty yeah they're just
like your eyes they're so pretty so this
is Angelina her mom has a blog called
living notes it's a really cool blog if
you guys wanna go check it out it's
really her Instagram is so pretty you
have to you know it's so cool to blue
like so beautiful here that they were
like what else can we make more
beautiful okay do you think it's amazing
you're all hot and sweaty my upper lip
is getting moist too look that building
is so pretty and pink I love it yeah
seconds of Internet
I've been turning it to dates really a
time I'd ready into what what does that
mean does that mean that you're not
having a good time in your board and the
time is going by too slow
or what were you trying to say with that
hope you do not look like having a good
time at all you said no no I mean I know
I know you're you're now you're turning
into a tween I know now he's turning
into a 20 twilight team-high 19 yet yes
it's like right before he hit the teen
years and so now he's like way warmest
that you're like way more mellow you're
like
cool I don't know mark all sweaty
who is that dude again yeah I gotta stop
being so what's the word like I don't
know yeah like a mom I'm always so
worried that I'm trying to make sure
you're having a good time
[Music]
so fun fact that cemetery behind me and
they see that wolves and fighting that
cemetery from the rest of the island
so apparently Carlos v I think it was
some king from Spain he was really
nervous about having the cemetery in the
city so you built a wall so to be
outside of the city and that's where he
had cemetery look how beautiful that's
like just a flame is in the room
[Music]
so fart wow you really wanted to run run
Isaac run he's like mommy mommy can I
run he's just booked it now run back
oh he's running back I was kidding cuz
it's uphill oh he gave up oh how cute
she asked if they wanted a picture if
you want a picture
Oh cute ah baby did you get shy do you
shine cuz you heard me say how cute
Evangelina I know you don't like your
full name but I love your name it's so
beautiful Evangelina yeah she wanted to
take a photo I want to take it was it a
nice picture can I see oh okay oh that's
a nice filter you tired baby oh I know I
got a place look at my chest right now
it was gross I'm gonna winning a window
there's those car place cars life Matt I
think they're gone that like the super
tiny little flies are throwing a cluster
oh my gosh she has to be here oh holy
hell oh my gosh no go to your eyeball Oh
get it up oh there we go oh my gosh this
wasn't your eyeball
oh they see you eat what you look it's
like a little fly oh my gosh over the
place oh my god they're all over you
dude my hair you get it almost almost
oh my god this is so weird Wow okay
don't walk over there that's where we
got all the flies on this they're not
gonna fight no I get like freaked out a
have like this phobia of like with like
the whole thing like one time I lean
over a sink that was filled with ant and
like the ants just covered my whole
chest and I cried so hard like I had
like I freaked out I panicked so seeing
Isaac covered and all that right now I
like trigger that again in my mind I
swallowed some extra protein
[Music]
it was like one slap of wood and then
like individual blanket and then the
shoes they didn't have a right or left
shoe it was just both of them are the
same size because you just got to go and
they were short to apparently like the
next to it
hey I'm as tall as they are
[Music]
now and maybe you can see through this
you don't need a porter
oh nice actually free I know he slaps me
hard assumptions like brushing Hough but
anyway this is a top of the fortress oh
yeah he keeps getting what happened wait
what happened
how cute you're wearing Isaac's backpack
how come you're wearing that because I
don't you want you wants to wear the
camera bag because I was making a sweat
thing get your friend sweat it looks so
funny on you cuz it's so small it's a
kids backpack very very colorful town
area right over there apparently that's
where they filmed this bus seat though
you know that song this bass seat better
did it yes all right there
[Music]
[Applause]
they're talking oh this is awesome we
have our own private view Oh what this
is a cool view nice fine baby what are
we doing now all right now
[Music]
oh nice day first time flying a kite I
remember flanked us and I was little
ever had a Barbie kite fish
[Music]
what are you doing Isaac
try it you read the bugs look like a
rabbit your nose yeah what was the
biggest are you for size
oh yes oh you're like oh yes and they
start jumping over them like he's such a
boy it's so funny
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you having a seizure
it's five minutes to midnight no to the
Sun fun isak was very very very very
very very very very very eager to go
downstairs to the beach so we're going
downstairs to the beach because when
else are we gonna get an opportunity to
see all this they're having a party
downstairs and could hear the music the
hotel's has like a DJ so there's a lot
of people partying it up downstairs
actually really wants to do a tradition
which is actually really sweet because
kids don't really care about this stuff
but it's really sweet that he cares okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people the beach man maybe
shoulda brought the other camera
he'll probably be better at night three
times all the way oh he's walking in
fact we can't be oh he's so tiny over
there
[Applause]
really you're cold so here's your towels
your bath babies it's like you're
cleansing yourself good job I was
actually planning on doing the same
thing to cook they got to some of the
ocean Casey and Isaac but I didn't so it
was really planning on doing the thing
too but I took a nap of an hour ago and
I woke up and I'm like man I'm tired I
don't even know if I could peel myself
away from the bed so at least I came
downstairs but I was not about to get
myself all wet and then have to shower
and do all like change and do all that
stuff right before I'm going to sleep
again because we have to attack still so
early flight tomorrow
maybe we can you know like we just got a
tiny little taste of worry yeah now
we're heading to the airport we're gonna
have a layover in Orlando and I'm so
excited because I get to see Jenny my
cousin and her brand-new baby boy name
is Axl we're gonna meet him
we had like about six-hour layover I'm
so excited I can't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they are visiting Jenny since she just
had her baby so they're here I mean you
were little - so they were playing video
games and Yvonne can't speak because he
has Down syndrome and so they had like a
miscommunication and episode and Isaac
is still to this day kicking myself in
the butt over that we're so sweet baby
he has such a tender heart but anyway
we're gonna call it uber and head over
there Oh Mickey Mickey Mouse Mickey
Mouse I mean with the Mickey boys saying
all the Harry Potter spilled so much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're gonna baby all to yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay you know it sucks
where's daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
flames with us
[Music]
your fight the first time experiencing
business
[Applause]
yeah where's your barefoot
[Music]